political correspondent ed O'Keefe is
with us for a closer look at the midterm
vote around the country Edie so good to
have you here this morning let's talk
first about the Senate because Democrats
face an uphill battle to retake the
Senate why cuz 10 of those Senate
Democrats are running in states that
Trump won right what are you looking at
three races we always worry about
Florida but three others to look at
Missouri where the Democrat Claire
McCaskill faces a strong challenge from
Republican Josh Holley
they've been neck and neck sometimes he
has the lead he's going to get a lot of
help from the president the vice
president the coming days because
Republicans think this is one they can
see if she can't hold that seat they
don't win the back they don't win back
the Senate bottom line and that's why
it's on the list at next race
Arizona where you have two women
Democrat Kyrsten Sinema Republican
martha mcsalley another squeaker where
cinema has a slight lead either way one
of these women will make history as the
state's for his female senator the third
state we look at Texas Ted Cruz has the
lead back to a raucous behind but given
all the money he has Democrats say watch
what he might be able to do in bringing
out new voters if he can win he defies
more than 20 years of history a Democrat
hasn't been elected statewide since 1994
you hear the president making proposals
for immigration that will never become
law why is he doing that because what
the Democrats wanted to be about health
care the debate absolutely he wants it
to be about him and his proposals to
drive up his base Democrats want to keep
it focused on things like health care
because they have a huge lead especially
on questions of which party will protect
pre-existing conditions or the ability
to get insurance despite them big leads
there Democrats have been campaigning on
this the entire cycle which is why
you've seen some Republicans start to
talk about it because they realize it's
a winning issue President Trump is going
to hold 11 rallies in eight states is
this election a referendum on President
Trump he wants it to be Democrats want
it to be and in some cases it probably
will be whether it's being a check or a
balance on him the Democrats say they
should be whether it's Republicans
saying that if you elect a Democratic
Congress we're gonna see two years of
impeachment battles and oversight
investigations he likely will be a big
factor in most of these races yeah I saw
in one of our CBS surveys in Florida
that 7 out of 10 voters said they are
gonna vote because of President Trump
either for him or against him absolutely
driving people to the polls yeah thank
you it and CBS News live coverage of the
midterm elections begins at CBS n next
Tuesday at 5:00 p.m. for Central and we
all be here for a prime-time election
night special starting at 9:00 8:00
central right here on CBS